[Music]
hey i get this i've been getting this
question a lot on the
internets on social media
and a couple of studies have come out
recently so i thought it's an important
thing to address
um
the question here's an email from sarah
and it just says can trauma cause weight
gain
and how do you work through enough
trauma that your body responds well to
things you're trying to do to lose
weight
so let me
take a stab at answering this
um
i want to think of trauma as your body
telling itself a story in the present
based on things that happened to it in
the past
okay so what does that mean that means
you were taking a left turn coming over
a hill and somebody t-boned you
in their truck because they were flying
down the road weren't paying attention
and somebody in your family passed away
and you were in the hospital for a while
now 20 years later every time you stop
in an intersection to take a left turn
you feel yourself getting antsy you grab
the wheel a little bit tighter your
heart starts beating faster
that's your body remembering in the
present something that happened to you a
long time ago and since our brains are
prediction machines and threat scanning
machines and i hate calling them
machines but just go with me here since
that's what your brain's doing all the
time it remembers they put a pin in that
hey when you're about to make a left
turn that's when somebody gets hurt so
when you're about to make a left turn
all of a sudden man your heart starts
beating fast you feel a little bit alive
your body fills up with stress and
cortisol adrenaline that's what it's
doing
or more insidiously
you had a feeling that i don't want to
be around that uncle i don't want to be
around that guy at my church i don't
want to be around that guy that teacher
like that makes me feel uncomfortable
and their parents said oh that's just
uncle so and so go give him a hug go sit
on his lap
or that's just sunday school teacher
bill go he's fine oh gosh my kid just
she's just shy
and that person
sexually abuses you
and whether it's a particular smell or a
particular
lighting arrangement or particular
way of talking or way of standing
whatever it is
your brain now is on the lookout
because certain relationships will get
you hurt so let's have none of them
okay
that's trauma right that's that's a
thing that happened that now our body is
trying to take care of us into the
future
all right so
whenever our body
hits the trauma button hey look out we
got to protect ourselves right it goes
into fight or flight or goes into freeze
and it floods your body with with
response chemicals to fight a bear or to
run from a bear or to hide from a bear
right
not to have to go to work every day
where they make fun of you and they are
merciless against you
um or not to have to be in a
relationship where someone's taken
advantage of you again because it
happened before and happened before that
happened before that and that's the
relationship that part of your body
knows and also the other part everybody
knows this relationship isn't safe right
so we play these things out over and
over and over again
a couple of things at play here
there are some studies that have come
out that suggest that say that women who
are obese are more likely to have
a significant number of them let me say
it carefully have experienced sexual
trauma
and some people pontificate they
um suggest that it might be somebody
unconsciously trying to make themselves
less presentable
so that people won't find them desirable
people won't try to sexually abuse them
other scholars suggest that it's a way
of hiding within yourself kind of like
when a kid puts their hair down in front
of their face my daughter does this
she'll like hide behind her own hair um
in the living room right or i used to
wear big giant baggy clothes because i
was a skinny kid and i wanted to look
bigger and tougher it's a way to hide
inside of yourself okay
um what i know is this i don't know the
ins and outs of the science i do know
this
trauma
when the kicks up for the fight or
flight sometimes our bodies want to go
grab cheap calories
to because we're gonna be running and
fighting things and so we're gonna grab
the nearest food and right now we have
an abundance of cheap calories that
we're gonna grab and grab and eat and
eat so that's number one yes so it's not
so much the trauma is causing obesity
but it's trauma
kicks off some behaviors
in our lives that then cause obesity
right see what i'm saying
um
paul conte's work the the brilliant he
wrote a great book called trauma
he's a psychiatrist i think he's in new
york or in california i'm pretty sure
new york um great book but he's told
numerous stories as a psychiatrist that
when he's treating somebody he's
treating somebody he's treating somebody
as a medical doctor and as a
psychiatrist
they deal with their trauma and boom
they lose 60 pounds they lose 30 pounds
their body releases that weight that
it's been using to protect itself or
maybe eating pattern shift or maybe
people can finally sleep and that less
that
the de-elevated uh
the de-escalated cortisol in the
bloodstream like whatever it happens to
be right we can go down the nerd thing
we're gonna do that
here's what i want you to know
when it comes to
how do you work through enough trauma
that your body responds well to things
you're trying to do to lose weight a
couple of thoughts there
number one here's how you quote unquote
heal from trauma
trauma healing is not that you forget
what happened you're not ever going to
forget what happened
it's that you can remember it in the
present and your body doesn't take off
on you
you remember the wreck when your husband
died
you remember when your granddad dropped
with a heart attack and you and your dad
tried to do cpr and he ended up dying
and you remember how hard your dad was
crying
and
you still get sad
but you can go about your day
that's healing from trauma i can i can
think about it
i can imagine it
but i don't re-experience it okay so
when someone asks me how do i heal from
trauma i keep thinking about it of
course you're gonna think about it
is your body taken off on you right is
your body trying to protect you still
then you haven't fully healed from it so
that's number one let's heal with the
trauma in a way that and i can talk
about it this happened
and it's super annoying and it still
pisses me off
but i don't lose control of my body and
number two ultimately losing weight
for most folks losing weight is dealing
with the psychology of it all and
dealing with a psychology so i can make
different behavioral choices
i can eat differently
i can change my food environment i can
make different choices and there's
plenty of research about when you get
tired you make bad
diet choices when you get stressed you
make bad diet choices these studies
linking of trauma to obesity right so
it's about the environment because
ultimately it's about what i'm putting
in my mouth right what i'm eating or not
eating and so
anybody who's had trauma
go deal with that
if you're struggling with losing weight
as a and you think it's connected in
some way have that conversation with
your mental health professional
also have that conversation with your
nutritionist or the person that you're
getting your workout from when we were
in california recently and i think the
interview will be coming out with the
mind pump guys i had some hard
conversations about
my history with disordered eating and
struggles i have with biodysmorphia and
the bar always moving on me and all this
kind of stuff and they taught me some
really important things that i've come
home in the last month and already
implemented right and that interview
will be dropping here in a few weeks i
think
um all i have to say is this
heal from your trauma
be highly intentional if you are
somebody who struggles with obesity meet
with your doctor meet with a mental
health professional and get on a plan
and then
feel less
think less
follow the plan
follow the plan follow the plan